now from potential future conservative
MPs to one of the party's most senior
figures the former leader in Duggan
Smith joins us now thank you very much
for being with us on the ground today
now
just speaking to Nigel frosh he says
he's open to a pact with the
Conservative Party at the next election
yesterday Jeremy Corbyn was in your seat
announcing his plans to try and scrap
universal credit he clearly thinks he
can win in that seat would a pathway the
brexit Party help you know I'm not
interested in really what other parties
say or do
Jeremy Corbyn was distinctly unwelcome
in my constituency and about 70 people
turned up and he shipped them all in
I've been doing nothing but campaigning
in my seat since the 2017 election and
what I do see is a lot of labour
supporters that used to support labour
now moving away from labour because of
the kind of appalling extremism
anti-semitism of the labour party so I'm
not in the slightest bit troubled by
what he was doing there I hope you
witnesses that for himself the reality
for us as a party and I heard you
earlier questioning is to make sure that
we recognize there's a distinct
difference between being supposedly in
the centre ground and then also
delivering on what democratically the
majority of the public have actually
voted for it's not an extreme position
to want to deliver brexit for those who
voted when they were promised or
whatever they succeeded in voting for
would be delivered and then there's all
the domestic stuff and I'm absolutely
the moon this morning because I have
campaigned for 20 years to get extra
money brought into the hospital my local
hospitals to have a rebuild and finally
today that 400 million has been
announced which will is a huge Philip to
all the doctors and nurses and people
who work in which Cross Hospital and I'm
over the moon that we finally got a
Conservative government not a Labour
government a Conservative government
investing in the future of whip across
hospital I think that's fantastic you're
talking about the need to deliver Brack
said to deliver the result of the
referendum and we've been speaking on
the show quite a lot about the been at
this idea that Parliament's compelled
the Prime Minister to seek an extension
rather than leave without a deal do you
think that the Prime Minister should
nor Parliament if a deal can't be
secured in time well it's not really
about ignoring Parliament the question
is really what did Parliament vote for
first of all this suppose it's surrender
Act which people refer to sometimes as
the been act is a mess it's a complete
shambles it had an amendment made to it
we don't know for certain whether that
amendment makes it absolute that they
have to write on the basis of the
amendment or on the basis of the
original text there's also the other
question which is really why does a
European Union administration why would
they want to force some kind of
extension on a clearly unwilling
government that does not want to have
that extension so there's an awful lot
of debate and discussion to be had but
Boris Johnson's quite within his rights
absolutely to say a personal to himself
he will not sign such an act I frankly
wouldn't do it myself either and we've
gone through a period where really
there's a lot of pompous and nonsense
being taught by people about
parliamentary sovereignty the people are
sovereign and they give their sovereign
authority to Parliament who exercise it
but when they have made a decision like
they've made and then they've got MPs
and all parties conniving to stop them
that's hardly the centre ground that is
the extreme and I think of those who are
blocking brexit now as extremists not
sent to ground people the centre ground
of British politics is to deliver on
what people voted for and that is what
Boris Johnson's determined to do and no
surrender Act should stop us I mean
you're talking about there that it's not
the centre ground to you know try and
stop brexit from happening but I think I
guess what some of the people expelled
from the party would argue is that
people have different views on brexit
that shouldn't mean that they can't be
in the broad tent of the Conservative
Party Philip Hammond for example telling
the times yesterday that the party is
unrecognizable to him in its place is an
ideological Puritanism that Brooks no
dissent I mean that's what's happening
is it no it's pompous claptrap honestly
all political parties you know I've been
in 27 years and I've rebelled against my
own government but there are times when
the party says to you categorically if
there are specific issues around how you
govern and how
you take that forward this is a vote of
confidence if you choose when it's clear
for reasonable reasons and after all as
one of your earlier guests said the
reason this was a vote of confidence
because Parliament was seeking to take
the power from government to actually
legislate which is almost completely
unprecedented therefore it's quite right
that a government says it's a vote of
confidence in the government if you vote
to strip power from that government now
people like the ex Chancellor and others
Oliver let when and kono very well that
had they been in any other time they
would have absolutely opposed such a
motion and so the very fact is that they
chose to do that was actually to vote
against their party's very strong wishes
and so they knew what they were doing
now I can remain friends with those
individuals I have much time for many of
them but I simply say to them you now
need to think about how you support your
government because that is the way back
I want to see as many as possible come
back into the Conservative Party but
they must start supporting the party and
the government it is not an extreme
government to make stupid statements
like that is to play holi into the hands
of a very extreme anti-semitic nasty
Labour Party which many Labour voters I
saw in a poll today don't want to have
in power so why would they want to play
games with that we need to defeat Jeremy
Corbyn and deliver on the British
people's vote I should probably put out
a point that Jeremy Corbyn and the
opposition would clearly refute the
suggestion that it's an anti-semitic and
party and just another question for you
while we're happy there's been a lot of
focus in Parliament this week saying
that the language around politics is
becoming top so that the debate is
becoming abusive that they're receiving
death threats and this of course is on
all size I should save of every debate
do you worry that it's now almost
dangerous to be an MP well actually I'd
like anybody else I've had death threats
I had one too a couple of nights ago
after I didn't interview on another
television network I'm against all of
that I think any [ __ ] who
issues death threats to anybody male or
female and I know that many women feel
more at risk of this they ought to be
pursued by the law immediately and dealt
with and in maybe it should be made very
clear that this is quite unacceptable in
any walk of life by the way not just for
politicians but it is in a sense part to
the trade now obviously clearly we want
to make sure that we moderate the way
that we conduct our affairs I'm quite in
favor of that but I do say that for all
the allegations that the Labour Party
was making about Boris Johnson actually
there was a concerted attempt the other
night I was in the chamber
I watched it concerted attempt to
personally attack Boris Johnson in ways
that I have not seen prior to this
calling him a cheat a liar a fascist I
heard all that screamed across and many
of those who are now moaning one or two
who actually were later on raising this
they were the worst offenders and Maria
Miller my colleague and friend
the following day pointed out a couple
of women on the Labour benches who she
said now moan that this all got out of
hand but they were screaming a vile
abuse at the Prime Minister through that
period if I had been speaker I would I'm
not going to be speaker by the way nor
do I want to be but if I had been I
would have cut that process short three
and a half hours was too long because
far too many people got wound up and he
should have cut it short I think and
said enough enough